foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
in our final show of the Year an icy
blast from Britain's top Bishop as
Christmas snowflakes we write
traditional carols to make them you
guessed it more inclusive we'll debate
that and we'll round out the year with a
completely uncensored and Brilliant
choir
and president zielinski defiantly tells
the U.S Congress that Ukraine will win
the war but did he win over Republicans
arguing it should be America First we'll
debate that
plus a festive cheer gulping Legend Ian
Poulter joins me live on the project
making dreams come true the seriously
unwelcome
here's here's Morgan uncensored
well good evening this is the final
Piers Morgan uncensored of 2022 the
final live one we're going to show some
of the best shows next week over the
festive restful periods you can gorge on
those with your turkey but for now we're
going to look back on the year it's that
time of year isn't it when you get
together with people that you love to
share a drink fall asleep in front of
the TV and then have a massive argument
about the year that's gone by within a
few minutes you might well be arguing
about me definitely won't be falling
asleep though because it hasn't been a
quiet one has it four British
chancellors three prime ministers two
reigning monarchs and a partridge in a
blazing pear tree this was the year we
sent covid packing we think we did and
discovered the new normal was actually
well quite normal we sweltered on the
hottest day on record we've celebrated
England won the Cricket World Cup
but not the football World Cup we opened
our homes to Ukrainian refugees
we queued for the late great Queen with
some notable exceptions it was a year
that began with a Will Smith slap and
then he was a slap in the face and led
his chancellor who decided we should all
pay a lot more tax after all
Boris Johnson was turfed out of Downing
Street for turning it into a mullet
that's business at the front parties at
the back it's a Christmas cracker Joe
this truss was kicked out of returning
down a street into a municipal car park
short stays only didn't even last as
long as the lettuce and the new prime
minister Rishi sunak United the
conservative party in wondering why the
hell he gave to Ella bravaman her job
back Elon Musk joined Twitter walked
away from Twitter still seems to be at
Twitter
we'll see what goes on but he wants to
save free speech and I'm behind him on
that Donald Trump's Red Wave turned out
to be a tiny red trickle the Qatar World
Cup began in a swirl of hypocritical
virtue signaling ended up being the best
World Cup we've ever had Cristiano
Ronaldo left Manchester United off an
explosive interview with a well an
explosive TV personality and one morning
in December watching Netflix I brought
up my breakfast thanks to the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex yes 2022 was a year
when nothing lasted it's been 12 months
of turmoil and transition but once again
we discovered that we're actually quite
good at this in a year when everything
changed collectively we didn't really
change at all nothing better sum that up
this year than the British Monarchy
first we celebrate equivalence versus
historic 70-year Reign at the Platinum
Jubilee beautifully in bitterly it
turned out to be our final chance to
show her what she meant to us but saying
goodbye to our Queen welcoming a new
king showed us that the monarchy is a
permanent and unifying force next year
we'll see the coronation of King Charles
and that Royal ribbon will pull us all a
little bit closer once again some
reports said the coronation will be
scaled back a little less lavish than
we'd expect it would be a recognition by
the monarchy that these are difficult
times for many people very sadly the
economic mess will get worse before it
gets better so will the cost of living
at least we are living it's an
appropriate time of year to remember the
tens of thousands of ukrainians have
died in defense of their country next
year with bills soaring a home it would
be tempting to question why we're
spending so much money and helping them
fight Putin's Russia the answer is
simply that they're fighting for all of
us the fund live in a world a free world
a democratic world where Sovereign
countries have a right to exist but
people get to choose who runs them and
how to live their lives Ukraine's
unshakable bravery in the face of
Russia's barbaric aggression is this
year's massive story of Hope if they can
survive and repel Putin surely we can
all survive the lumion recession
we also say goodbye to some Legends this
year meatloaf Madeleine Albright Ray
Liotta Robert LuPone James Khan Olivia
Newton John Mikhail Gorbachev Angela
Lansbury Robbie Coltrane Hillary
mantel's name just a few but a new year
means new possibilities new challenges
new debates in 2023 Putin will try and
fail in my estimation the bully Ukraine
and the Western to submission Prince
Harry will once again trash his family
in his attention seeking woe is me
Memoir Joe Biden and Donald Trump with
their combined 156 years will hopefully
decide to put their country before
further runs for the White House
meanwhile Florida Governor Ronald
DeSantis will urge Republicans to surely
dump Trump and run with him there'll be
a Rugby World Cup Eurovision
unfortunately returns this time to the
UK for the first time since 1998.
Arsenal will absolutely definitely win
their first premier league title since
2004 possibly my New Year's resolution
will will be to speak my mind it's been
a while to call out chaos and
incompetence in the corridors of power
to bring you the interviews the whole
world talks about to constantly and
supremely irritate all the right people
so more of the same really and why not
because it's our turbulent 2022 As Told
as anything it's surely that we're at
our very best when we do it the way we
know best and when we are completely
uncensored well my guest is here have
most certainly been uncensored
only a fool only a fool would think that
was a legitimate you think I'm a vote I
do now yeah you can say it won't bleep
you I came to my senses
and kicked it
that doesn't mean to me the guy's been
doing the same effing part for 35 years
I kind of only came on here because I
thought it would be kind of funny
um but I want to say you're don't bother
me anymore
how about if you do fight again you have
to give me a million pounds how about
that's a deal if I ask you what a woman
is what would you say a human being with
a boobs
I've been trying to work out how much
money you must have made from American
Pie if everybody that knows that song
came to my shows I'd be selling out
stadiums the greased piglet of politics
has slipped and squirmed through almost
three disastrous years of disorder and
deceit what would last longer this
lettuce or Liz trust I am resigning as
leader of the conservative party the
letters want these constant High Radia
against Jewish people you don't hold
accountability to my pain you're being a
Karen a man protect the woman and
provide for her so we need to make sure
that she's safe he needs a degree of
authority no problem no but no you but
people do have a problem with it and
that's the word we're in now I'm over
here
there's nobody in this country or the
world who hasn't lived the majority of
their lives under the reign of Queen
Elizabeth II this is how she wanted her
funeral to be and like everything the
Queen ever did it just showed Immaculate
taste uh unbelievable class and dignity
nothing and nobody has symbolized what
it means to be British
better than Queen Elizabeth
they're trying to force you out yes not
only the coach but the other two or
three guys there around
the club that I felt to betrayed it was
stated that Elvis you know uh with a
racist he's never been a racist when she
said that Olivia Wilde it stung you
didn't it I thought the marginalized
we're supposed to have a voice Andy I
mean you've alluded to the fact that
you've had Suicidal Thoughts at one
stage yeah I was close to going down the
garden where I used to have a point down
at the Garden with a little bottle and a
few poles and I would I was that bad one
day do you believe you can win this war
yeah
I don't only believe it I know it will
happen we will win we already showed the
whole world that he can kill us but to
conquer our people is impossible
she gave me if I look a bit sweaty and
moist the girl he's apparently liked it
that way no problem with the tits no
problem with the tips no tips aren't
really involved in there
oh thank you peers interview adjourned
love you
turn the camera off
like I said it's all been a quiet year
but who wants a quiet Year anyway the
hospital for Westminster has criticized
the washing some of our most cherished
carols supposedly to eliminate sensitive
phrases the revised God Rest Ye Merry
Gentlemen sung at a church of England
service in the Midlands this week
retains just two lions from a 17th
century original it now includes lyrics
including God Rest You also women who by
men have been erased yeah more on that
in a moment but first there's a
brilliant Choir in my studio tonight the
gospel touch choir who are based here in
London have come together to show what
God Rest Ye Merry Gentlemen should sound
like take it away
God Rest Ye Merry Gentlemen and nothing
you display
remember Christ Our Savior was born on
Christmas day to save us open Satan's
but when we were gone astray oh Tidings
of Comfort and Joy comfortable and joy
oh Tidings of Comfort and Joy
I loved you know what just carry on for
a bit can you I don't want you stopping
in your Prime we weren't going to cut
you off there but I'm liking that so
much just keep singing finish just keep
going
[Applause]
thank you very much we will have a lot
more from the gospel touch choir later
in the program they are brilliant All
Acapella no musically compliment other
than me tapping my feet which is almost
certainly ruining their Rhythm but
they're brilliant thank you very much
gospel touch we're back with you a
little later now they couldn't leave it
alone could then American Minister wrote
a new inclusive version of that song
we've just heard so beautifully
performed at a church in Loughborough
leicestershire and here it is God Rest
You also women who by men have been
erased through history ignored and
scorned defiled and displaced remember
that your stories too are held within
God's grace
God Rest You Queer and questioning your
anxious Hearts be still
believe that you are deeply known and
part of God's good will
for all to live as one in peace the
global dream fulfilled so rather
different to the original joining me now
to debate this extraordinary development
is the former conservative cabinet
minister and Catholic and Whitaker along
with Jane ozan who's a prominent gay
Evangelical Christian so a high-powered
panel here to debate this Al whitakam
your thoughts on this revised version of
this classic
well honestly sometimes I really do
Wonder uh if everybody's going mad I
mean what are we going to have next are
we going to have three wise women
are we going to have questioning
Shepherds watching their flocks and
writing their pronouns on the Sheep's
fleeces I mean you know where does this
actually stop now if you want a new
Carol write a new Carol deviser tune and
let it see if it can compete with the
traditional ones but don't mess about
with traditional carols which everybody
enjoys and everybody wants to enjoy and
this is the central message of Christmas
is certainly not a woke one okay Jane
ozone I mean I remember a big fuss when
John Legend rewrote the lyrics to Baby
it's cold outside because the woke
Brigade suddenly decided it was about
sexual assault uh what John Legend
didn't do was seek to rewrite any of the
lyrics of his rapper friends where the
lyrics are often really quite disgusting
so I found that a double standard and a
pointless intervention in an old
seasonal classic and I kind of feel the
same I'm kind of leaning with Anne why
why go back and try and rewrite Classics
like this when you could just go and do
your new one
because I think the whole point is is
that Christmas is about a wonderful gift
of love for everyone and there's an
awful lot of people who turn up in our
churches perhaps the first time or
perhaps for one time a year who are
feeling quite hurt and damaged by the
church I'm a gay Evangelical as you said
I nearly died because of the Christian
teaching I sat under it's quite hard
sometimes going into church and so to
hear some words that say actually this
is good news this is Tidings of
um joy for you you LGBT people or you
women I mean let's be fair the whole
Carol starts with God Rest You married
gentlemen well that gets rid of half the
congregation in in one one line so I
think sometimes it's good to to to bring
things into the modern day how many
times do we sing cows
familiar Jane if your problem is that it
actually involves the word gentleman do
you have a problem with the with the
lunar Landing when man landed on the
moon when three men landed on moon and
Neil Armstrong
Neil Armstrong well hang on to be
finished let me ask you the question
first
and Neil Armstrong
Neil Armstrong stood on the moon and
said one small step for man one giant
leap for mankind because it would be you
would find that entire sentence very
offensive now because anyone watching or
listening to that who wasn't a man would
have been excluded so do we now go back
and edit the Neil Armstrong tape and
make it one small step for men and women
and then the three of us are blokes
right so let's be honest there's a lot
of hymns that are Rewritten these days
to make sure that they are inclusive
that's been going on for years
um and in fact most of our ancient and
modern hymn books do that quite normally
but I think the important thing is to to
understand the message of Christmas
which is about God's love for everyone
and we need to get out of our way to
make sure people really do sense
no disrespect you talk about God that's
the message of Christ but the original
message of this of this song is actually
very heartwarming the enemy is Satan
he's the only one singled out for uh for
for negativity whereas in the revised
version women have been by men who are
now the enemy erased ignored scorned
with fires I'm sorry but it's a lot of
women that is an unbelievable I just
finished my question Jane again that is
an unbelievable
it's an unbelievable attack on men why
why alienate every man listening to that
because we know that the church has for
many many years subjugated women they've
not been allowed to be
um in in positions of leadership but
more than that they haven't been treated
well when we've looked at sexual abuse
cases there's a lot of women whose
stories have been
um squashed and I think it's important
to lift people up I mean you you
yourself have been quite as you know
outspoken against certain women recently
and that causes deep pain and harm well
actually well hello again if you're
talking about Meghan Markle I would
argue she's been very outspoken herself
about members of the royal family a lot
of people in this country share my view
that that has been pretty disgraceful so
I'm afraid if she gets a bit of
criticism
I think the problem is how we
how we use our powers in those
situations look the truth of this story
is that it has been liked thousands and
thousands of times that the hymn has
been shared hundreds of times on my own
timeline it's been shared there were
four people who spoke out against it and
the telegraph ran a story saying outrage
the Archbishop of Westminster didn't
actually condemn it in the way that
others are saying they just said look we
like it all right let me go let me go to
one as you're waiting there's quite an
agenda here well there is an agenda the
agenda is to turn it from a perfectly
harmless lovely Carol into a man-hating
load of abuse
impatiently Anne I mean does anything
that you're hearing uh from Jane or
Sanders change your mind
I wouldn't describe myself as listening
patiently
um I think the opposite uh is true uh
the fact is that if you talk about men
they're raising women and cast men as
the enemy then that is going against the
Central Christian message and the
central message of Christmas which is
good will to everyone now I consider
myself included if people talk about
Mankind and man doing this and and Etc I
consider myself included in that and I
have no problem with God Rest You Merry
Gentlemen I immediately conjure up a
vision of victorians in top hats and and
you know welcoming Christmas and all the
rest of it uh and uh it is joyful there
is nothing joyful about that miserable
substitute which sets up a war between
the Sexes absolutely I completely agree
with you I'm sorry jay knows that
there's a way to there's a way to
transfers a thousand Stones agree with
you you talk about love and peace
all you've got is a rant against men
we're awful we've erased women we've
ignored you we've scored and displaced
you happy Christmas my God
well we're recognizing the pain that so
many people I shared just now that I
nearly died because of the teaching of
the church and so to try and speak into
that pain and make people know that
actually God loves them God includes
them God wants the best for them and
that's the wonderful message of
Christmas and it's fantastic that we can
share that yeah I'm sorry again again I
know that there are ways to do that
without trashing men every man who
listens to this new version is going to
think they're being accused of erasing
it all around the morning defiling and
displacing women and I'm sorry as a man
I think that's pretty objectionable
but you get a whole first verse appears
why can't you allow women to have a
second verse and to recognize that the
the problems that many women have faced
in the church particularly in the
Catholic church where they're still not
recognized so I think I think actually
this is about healing people and
allowing people to feel that they're
included and and I think it's great that
we we are trying to refresh hymns and uh
cows in a way that allows people to know
that God loves them God's there for them
and that's the president are we going to
change are we going to change all the
songs with women in the title to make
them more inclusive with John Lennon's
woman now be changed to woman and man
well I you you're talking about
completely different things aren't you
you think I am a message of Christmas do
you want to be inclusive hang on you
want to be inclusive right to the point
it includes men and final word to you
yes um I've just been told that uh women
aren't recognized in the Catholic Church
vast number of the Saints are women and
who is the central figure apart from the
baby Christ himself who is the central
figure of Christmas Mary so don't say
that we marginalize women I frankly
pears
a big nonsense that I wouldn't expect to
hear from the kindergarten well on that
bombshell I'm going to leave it there
Merry Christmas to both of you and an
inclusive New Year thank you very very
much indeed for joining me well coming
next uh president zolenski makes his
pitch for America's continued support in
his war against uh Vladimir Putin's
barbarians who've invaded his country
with a divided Congress the cost of
living crisis will Americans continue to
back that war on the Ukrainian side
evading that next
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
jingle bells jingle bells jingle all the
way oh what fun it is
[Applause]
[Music]
jingle bells jingle bells jingle all the
way
[Music]
hey jingle bells jingle bells jingle all
the way fabulous
[Music]
absolutely love it gospel touch from
London nailing it tonight my choir
fantastic
well to more serious matters president
zielinski is returning to Ukraine
tonight after an historic visit to
United States his first international
trip since Russia's Invasion back in
February it's been 81 years since the
Winston Churchill speech to the U.S
Congress change the course of the second
world war and zelenski told lawmakers
that Ukraine will never surrender
President Biden to his credit pledged to
support him for as long as it takes to
defeat Vladimir Putin
he's going to fail he's already failed
because he now knows that there's no way
he's ever going to occupy all of Ukraine
there's no way in which he's going to be
accepted by the Ukrainian people and so
uh he's failed in the past and was very
important uh for him and everyone else
to see the president of zelinski and I
are united two countries together to
make sure he cannot succeed
well joining me to discuss all this is
Ukrainian MP Kiera ruddick and
conservative commentator Ben Ferguson
let me start with you Ben Ferguson
because there are some Republicans not
all but there are some who think that
Americans should not be getting involved
in this war at all not America's
business and Joe Biden should not be
committing so much money when there are
more pressing and Urgent needs back home
domestically what's your view
look I think there's certainly some
truth to that the reality is we have a
wide open Southern border right now we
have a humanitarian crisis on the border
you have freezing conditions now with
this Arctic blast and there's 10 000
people they're saying they're Crossing
on average per day right now and Joe
Biden's in Washington trying to protect
Ukraine from an invasion it's hard to
look at those two issues and to separate
them when it comes to the logic of the
present the second part is the money why
is it that America is funding the
majority of this bill and others around
the world are not can we afford it with
the debt that we have right now the
answer I think is no and the other part
is this when you go all in the way that
that Joe Biden has done with this virtue
signaling what happens if Vladimir Putin
does escalate things are you then going
to take us into a World War III uh and
and this is a country that I understand
Aid and support I don't blame zielinski
for coming here and getting every dime
he can what worries me is the people in
Washington seem to care care more about
virtue signaling and standing next to a
Guy in fake Army fatigues and they
actually do about the American people
dealing with inflation in an open border
this is a massive problem for them I
think moving forward I mean I could not
disagree with you more about almost
everything you want to say well a
because I went to Ukraine I met
president zielinski I think he's an
incredibly honorable and decent man
waging an inspirational battle to save
his country's democracy and freedom from
an invading Barbarian in Vladimir Putin
and I'm also curious did you for example
did you support America's military
action to repel Saddam Hussein from
Kuwait
yeah I also think we learned from that
yeah
hang on
what on Earth does Kuwait have to do
with America it wasn't even in NATO so
why would you support repelling Saddam
Hussein from Kuwait when it wasn't even
anything to do with NATO
why would you support that but you
wouldn't support this absolute
full-fledged assault ground invasion of
a free Democratic country in Ukraine
explain the difference again I go I go I
go back to what I said I think when you
make mistakes you learn from those
mistakes in my foreign policy in the
Middle East even Post 9 11 has changed
the idea that you can send democracy
around the world and pick winner and
losers and somehow it's going to change
things look at the debacle in
Afghanistan I learn when you make
mistakes and the mistake that I'm
worried about right now is we're going
to get ourselves to the brink of World
War III and we've decided that we are
going to Virtue signal and take care of
a country as you mention it not a part
of NATO Etc and you do that while you're
also cannot afford it at the end of the
day can the United States of America
afford to foot this bill to the majority
of Americans want to spend this much
money right now if you look at what the
polls say the majority of Americans
aren't exactly sure about this decision
let me take money away it doesn't make
sense when did Republicans get so soft
with dictators I don't understand it I'm
literally history of software you would
rather Vladimir Putin you would rather
Vladimir Putin marauds his way around
the world invading Sovereign Democratic
countries taking their territory like
Adolf Hitler did back in 1939 what would
you have done what would you have done
in 39 women when Hitler invaded Pierce
what would you have wanted America to do
I understand I understand the narrative
I go back to what I said earlier all
right don't put words in my mouth I'm
pretty direct with you I made it clear
it can't just be America that's putting
the bill for this wants to get in the
game and I would says to you where the
hell is the funding coming from the UK
why aren't you guys
we're putting a lot of money in the
United States of America you guys are
not no you're not you said you were but
you're actually not nowhere close to
what America's put in here
are funding okay let me bring in let me
bring in a very very patient Ukrainian
MP Kiera ruddick Kieran when you hear
that do you feel disheartened that and
to me it's inexplicable that Republicans
who would normally be the first to want
to take on people like Putin now seem to
want to just let Putin get away with it
and do whatever he likes
well from my understanding it's not a
general position of the Republican party
but of just some of its members but I
totally understand that there could be a
concern about the funds that need to be
used and we have a very good solution to
that and this solution would work in the
united states in the United Kingdom in
Canada in European countries is instead
of using taxpayers money to cover for
Putin's crimes let's use Putin's money
to cover for his crimes a it's about 500
billion dollars of Russian money
Sovereign Russian bank money that are
being stored around the world including
United States including United Kingdom
so let's go ahead and use those money to
cover all the expenses that you want and
I think that will make the argument
about spending too much on Ukraine uh
obsolete yeah I know this is not it's a
very good point but
hang on let me ask you a question it
comes back to this in the end doesn't it
are you happy are you content if
Vladimir Putin
wins in Ukraine and then starts to go
into other countries restoring in his
eyes the Soviet Union would you be happy
for Putin look I try and restore the
Soviet Union without the American
military power half the world's military
power in one country actually helping to
stop it let me
again let me let me answer that I think
he is obviously a crazed man right now
trying to put back the SSR this is
Manifest Destiny for him but I'll say it
the same way they've said it before it
can't all be on America so I would say
to you peers why don't you go to your
neighbors in the UK right now and around
you and say stop buying the damn oil and
gas and doing deals in Russia and why
don't you actually cut off the money
flow that goes into Russia go talk to
Germany go talk to other countries that
have actually keep giving money to
Vladimir Putin if you want to actually
stop this war then you got to stop
buying this product okay he's the drug
dealer and you keep buying his drugs
second thing don't look at Americans say
I'm abandoning Ukraine when you guys
aren't writing the damn checks go to the
rest of Europe and write the checks you
want to match American Funds then I look
at it a little bit differently but I am
not a bank account for the world and all
of you guys in Europe you always say
you're on board with fighting people
hell you've dealt with it with World War
one and World War II and yet you don't
write the check so maybe take some money
from the monarchy and throw it together
okay to fight Vladimir Putin that would
be a great idea I'll support you in it
okay we actually have contributed to
another billion pounds so far not an
insignificant double number we'll be
doing the same again
if you're going to harangue us about not
contributing you should actually know
what we've contributed let me go back
look at how much money we've given
compared to you you're a massively
wealthier you're saying this you guys
care less in the UK about beating Putin
than Americans do based on the dollar
amount the UK cares less about beating
Putin than America does we care more
than anybody else why should we always
pay the bill all right let me come back
to Takira I gotta say I found president
zielinski's visit to Congress incredibly
moving and inspiring it did remind me of
Churchill when he went there he does
remind me of Churchill because he has
led the resistance with his inspiring
leadership I mean I find him incredibly
impressed both when I met him and when
I've been watching him in action what is
the feeling in Ukraine about zielinski
and about his leadership
we are bursting with fried tears we are
and I was honestly in tears when I was
listening to his speech he was
the concentration of what we feel what
we do and what we think as a nation and
he was able to deliver it to the whole
world and to U.S president U.S Congress
and U.S Nation we are incredibly proud
and we hope that this is the Turning
Point into this war that this is the
time when uh something that nobody ever
believed would happen is happening and
something that nobody believes that we
will receive the Patrick missiles we
will receive and that will lead to to
other countries coming along because if
you want to be a leader of the
democratic free world you need to do
what leaders do be the first one next
have decisions yeah Show an example
yeah I've got to say I think it's on gas
well hang on I criticize President Biden
a lot in the last year but I've got to
say I think on this he's been
outstanding in his leadership he
understands that actually the ukrainians
can't win without American help and a
lot of it and Ben you may not like that
but actually it's a fight for freedom
and democracy but thank you both for
joining me Ben Ferguson Kiera running I
appreciate it Merry Christmas to both of
you and to the people of Ukraine Merry
Christmas fighting I can tell you it is
a battle worth fighting for and a battle
that must be won well coming up next a
true mini of Christmas golfing Legend
Ian Poulter joins me to tell me how he's
helping to make children's dreams come
true
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and heaven and nature see
[Applause]
fabulous the gospel touch choir with Joy
to the World it's the season of Joy to
the World and giving in tonight what
does it take some time to talk about
some special people who actually do a
lot more than most to bring Joy to the
World by giving back the British charity
dream flight takes children with
disabilities and serious illnesses on
holidays of a lifetime to Orlando in
Florida was this the first flight in
1987 more than 6 000 children have made
the trip which is often transformative
in their personal battles with illness
Aidan Healy flew in 2009 suffering from
a rare autoimmune disease it's gone on
to make an astounding recovery becoming
a professional golfer and striking up a
friendship with Ryder Cup hero Ian
Poulter well Ian is a dream flight
Ambassador himself and Patricia Pierce
is the Charities co-founder we're going
to hear from all three of them in a
moment
but earlier this month Ian's charity Cup
Day raised 1.5 million dollars in one
night for dream flight
[Music]
we reached the total last night of 1.5
million dollars
[Applause]
a staggering sum of money I'm glad to
say the founder of dream flight Patricia
Pierce is here with Ambassador
professional golfer Aiden Healy and
girlfriend Ambassador Ian Foster is also
joining me from across the pond there's
The Great Mouse we'll come to me in a
moment Patricia great to see you so you
were there you were in the late 80s you
were a ba stewardess flying around the
world having a great time and you
decided you were going to make a
difference what was the original vision
for dream flight for you I think it was
too much wine one night and it seemed
like a good idea and flying and then yes
I just wanted to any child that's
suffering something I think they deserve
a treat in life what I love about the
dream flights that you do each year this
plane takes off with 192 kids with a
whole backup team they don't bring any
family or anyone with them they're on
their own and they get this 10-day
bonding experience where they all come
together with other kids you've gone
through tough stuff that I think is what
makes this special it's not those they
pop over and go to Disneyland they have
10 days with other kids who've been
suffering it appears a lot of the
children that maybe in a wheelchair or
something are in class at school they're
the odd one out they can't do everything
that the other class members do but you
put 192 children all on one aircraft all
have something wrong with them there is
no odd one out well Aiden you were one
of those kids how old were you when you
went on the flight I was 14 back in
2009. what was it like the experience
for you just incredible just the whole
Buzz of getting from getting the
invitations like six months before to
the build up of it and obviously at the
time I was really struggling health-wise
and just that Bill's knowing what he was
going to do and then the surprise of
them meeting Ian on the planet Ian Paul
is obviously as a golfer and sort of
wants to stemmed just the most
incredible 10 days being with other kids
like past said around you do you know
where I say I was Ill but there was
other kids that were worse off than
right and it sort of just give me the
Boost really uh might say you felt
normal being with everybody but the
attention the detail that dream fight
goes to as well not just the theme parks
but I say getting off the plane in the
closet highways off for you and things
like that it's just it just gives me
goosebumps it was incredible you were in
a wheelchair I think for several years
right the worst of this and now you're a
professional golfer up in Leeds you play
off scratch I am I am I've been playing
golf 40 years I'm off 16. that's amazing
thank you yeah yeah just never in my
wildest dreams did I think that was
going to happen is actually speaking to
Ian Paul well the postman as we call him
because he always delivers he does
delivery how did your relationship come
about the two of you so I met Ian off
the Berlin back in 2009 was on the trip
um powers and you'll upload Golf and he
sort of just developed from there really
we did a bit for our Golf Channel and as
friendship sort of started from there
really started doing the charity golf
days at Woburn yeah
um invited me down to play now which was
incredible have you beaten him yet or
not not quite not quite well let's bring
in let's bring in the postman Ian
Poulter fellow gooner we're going to win
the league aren't we in first question
come on
polls I know this chat you've been
involved with dreams right now for 14
years it's a real commitment from you
and that figure you raised the other day
was really startling I mean one and a
half million dollars in one night to
help these kids and that will pay for
another flight next year and so on why
does it mean so much to you what what
does it give you back just being able to
do this
well appears it's astounding
um and when you get to spend some time
with Pat like you are tonight you get to
realize how much of an amazing character
she is to have the vision to want to
bring this trip on and to do it as a
one-year thing and a one-year dream and
now to think you know this year was 34
years you know I've been really a taken
aback of you know how her team how the
volunteers and what they give back to
dream flight
um really transformed me when I met
Aiden in 2009 uh just across the pond
over there at you know Orlando
International Airport
um and it it just blew me away it really
did it was very special to see you know
how these kids transform their
personalities change their confidence
um and it was at that time that I was
like okay you know I need to do more I
need to give back more I want to try and
build an amazing golf day which we can
try and raise as much money as possible
and you know through the golf community
Through friends through CEOs and great
people that I've met inside this great
game you know we've been able to achieve
that and um you know 1.5 is actually 1.6
million amazing um but that that was
absolutely remarkable and that we've got
Pat sitting here I wanted to get you on
um all of you so I mean what would you
say about her Ian as she sits here
squirming if I import a badge she's
wearing her I love Ian Poulter badge by
the way so you can lay it on with a
trowel
ah listen Pats Pat's just that's just
incredible
um you know to know that there's
somebody in the world that gives back
like she does
um it's it's pretty amazing Pat's never
taken a penny salary out of the charity
from day one she does this from a love
of her heart she's built this business
that helped all of these children and
there's only a few members of staff that
actually run this whole this this whole
trip so you know that for me is has kind
of been pretty special to get to see her
energy to get to see what you know what
means a lot to Pat in giving back you
know you can take a lot from from those
types of people and Pat is a very
special lady I completely agree uh
Paul's great of you to join tonight uh
Pat it's really about you we've got the
Superstar golfer but he's he's you know
playing second fiddle tonight even I'm
sure a new degree too very special lady
do an incredibly special thing and to
see Aiden to see his story is really the
proof of what you do and what you give
these kids you and you make them feel
confident about going back into the
world again and then you end up being a
professional golfer like embolden quite
an amazing story great to meet you uh
great to see you uh Ian Merry Christmas
to you mate uh we'll meet again when I
also win the league if that's the right
we'll have a longer interview then uh
but Pat thank you on behalf of everybody
that you've helped thank you you're a
little saint and be greatly appreciated
thank you so much peers you're gonna
have to get a team ready to come over to
Orlando next year you know what I think
it's a great idea why don't we do that
great idea lovely to see you all and
Merry Christmas thank you very much well
coming next it was the year little
lettuce in a week outlasting Liz trust
his career as prime minister I'll look
back at the moments we'll cherish and
those we'd rather forget from 2022.
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's been an extraordinary year hasn't
it in so many ways I mean Richard for
you highs and lows oh I think the most
extraordinary and the saddest bit of
course was the passing of uh her late
Majesty Queen Elizabeth II and just
everything around that I was desperately
concerned at that moment as to what
would happen but actually in a sense
we're coming through that relatively
strongly it's all the other challenges
around it the political loads has been
an absolute catastrophe for this country
and I I really do worry about next year
I think it's going to be a really
difficult any highs for you uh the highs
I guess out of tragedy you touched
earlier on uh president zielinski uh his
um just his ability to motivate and
Infuse a nation under threat is is an
extraordinary inspiration which will go
down in history and England winning the
Cricket World Cup of course will be top
of your list I'm sure I I what can I say
to that I have to defer to this one I
mean for me I think the political
movement of the year was when Liz trost
sacked quasi-quarters yes I mean you
know as a political gender for doing
what she told him absolutely gobsmacking
moment and at that moment I just knew
the government has her Administration
has to collapse yeah so that was
extraordinary and in terms of the highs
they're pretty few and far between and
you couldn't really call this a high but
I would say that the way that the
country came together after the queen
died and the pageantry of that all those
kind of commemorations in the week after
well it reminded us that we do have some
things we can unite together the vast
majority of Brits came together for that
and felt the same way about it and we
were good at it yes and we're not really
good at anything else right now but once
again of course it was the military it
was the Armed Forces who came together
the logistics the the pageantry the
ceremony absolutely Split Second perfect
and you sort of said well if they can do
it why can't large parts of the rest
it's the biggest problem right now have
we lost the ability to debate in the way
we used to oh that is a really important
I think to me that's the biggest problem
in society we should better go hammering
tongs and then go and have a plane
what's happened to that it's become so
he hasn't it so I had a moment on um
Mike Graham's show on talk radio talk TV
last week where I dared to suggest that
not all nurses are angels and that not
all nurses work incredibly hard so
whilst I fully support their demands for
more pay and I think that the vast
majority of them are overworked not all
are equal the hatred and bile that has
been poured on my head as a result of
making that question and suggesting that
perhaps the debate could be more nuanced
it's quite extraordinary
and and also just some subjects that
you're not allowed to debate right
you're literally not even allowed to go
there and I think it's actually it's
corrosive for society and it will
diminish our ability to there should be
nothing that we can't openly debate I
felt this for a while it's why I wanted
to set this show up it's like this idea
that we're all being quietly censored
yeah and in fact not even that quietly
now whereas things like gender and all
this kind of thing huge issues by the
way with massive repercussions for
society that if you mention the wrong
word at the wrong time about these
issues you get canceled have we been
what North Korea does I mean look at the
treatment of Lady Hussey I mean I don't
think that what she said was right I
think it was clumsy and inelegant and
crass and many other things but I don't
think that she needed to be traduced in
the way that she she was over really
just a mistake well I know that while
I'm off next week you two are going to
be stepping into the whole first week of
January right that's right uh you're in
the hot seat Well I Lounge on the beach
many miles away I will be watching we'll
send you great messages it's basically a
takeover bit of course of course of
course it is uh best of luck to you and
you'll take over a bit it won't work but
I do wish you best and Merry Christmas
to both of you thank you good to see you
both well to sing us out for the show of
the last time this year but we will be
back with some specials next week of all
the big highlights from Trump to Kanye
to Cristiano Ronaldo but for now we're
going to leave you with the gospel touch
choir from London with Hark the Herald
Angels Sing that's it from me I'll see
you in early January Merry Christmas
whatever you're doing Keep It Uncensored
[Music]
glory to the newborn king peace on Earth
[Music]
[Applause]
by the skies
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
glory to the newborn please
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]